clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi ça leur banc ça
ouais super et toi bats pas où je dors
pas très très bien en ce moment
je comprends totalement moi si j'ai pas
mes 22 heures de sommeil par jour
je suis bon à rien à temps vingt deux
heures de sommeil mais comment tu fais
du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dormir nous connaissez c'est un ben
ouais c'est sympa et c'est vital un peu
comme manger par exemple le problème
c'est qu'il suffit de vraiment pas grand
chose pour dérégler tous à dormir comme
manger mais là aujourd'hui on va parler
du sommeil alors vous avez sûrement déjà
entendu le fameux attendent et
rencontrons d'or huit heures par nuit ça
veut dire qu'on passe un tiers de nos
demis influence mais c'est fou ou quoi
ça pis c'est fou à un tiers oui sauf que
non on dort pas huit heures par nuit
quand on dort plus huit heures par nuit
en cinquante ans on a perdu en moyenne
1h30 de sommeil et je vous parle même
pas de la qualité du sommeil
mais avant de parler de tout ça le
sommeil qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
alors le sommeil c'est dormir c'est vrai
mais pas seulement bon on va commencer
par le début notre petite horloge
biologique personnel elle fonctionne
selon un rythme qui s'appelle le rythme
circadien qui dure 24 heures et qui
détermine un autre rythme le rythme
veille sommeil alors hyper complexe mais
parmi tous les phénomènes qui
interviennent là dedans il ya notamment
le fait que notre organisme synthétise
de la mélatonine la mélatonine c'est ce
qu'on appelle parfois l'hormone du
sommeil et sa fabrication elle
intervient entre le coucher et le lever
du soleil donc dans l'obscurité
c'est pour ça qu'on dans la nuit et
qu'on dort mieux dans le noir mais la
mélatonine c'est pas juste une espèce de
somnifères naturelle elle a des effets
sur plein de trucs comme le système
immunitaire la fabrication des
spermatozoïdes
le cycle menstruel et cetera mais bon
c'est quand même elle qui détermine
alternance veille sommeil et c'est ce
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui alors
être réveillé ça vous savez ce que ça y
est vous rendez compte de ce qui se
passe vu que quand ça nous arrive a
justement que vous êtes réveillé mais le
sommeil vous avez sûrement entendu
parler truc à base de rythme de phase ii
siffle donc cérébrale et c'est bon
qu'est ce que c'est que ces histoires
grâce aux électroencéphalogramme on est
capable depuis un petit moment
maintenant de mesurer l'activité
électrique de notre cerveau et donc
d'étudier
fameuses ondes cérébrales et ils sont il
y en a plusieurs tiff les ondes bêta
c'est elle que le cerveau et mais à un
rythme de 12 à 30 par seconde quand on
est réveillé avec une activité normale
certains parlent aussi dont ghana à plus
de 30 à 40 par seconde quand on a une
activité cérébrale intense les ondes
alpha ça c'est quand on est réveillé
mais au calme quand on se relâche quand
on fait le vide et le cerveau en émet 8
à 12 par secondes seulement si on se
pose encore plus ce genre si on fait de
la méditation on passe en ont et aa 4 à
8 par seconde et enfin quand on est en
phase de sommeil profond
notre cerveau émet des ondes delta au
rythme de 0,5 à 4 par seconde alors pour
être complet il faut ajouter que
l'absence totale dont cérébrale c'est à
dire un électroencéphalogramme plat ça
correspond à la mort cérébrale
chez l'ambiance bon bref vous avez
compris quand vous dormez vous passez
par toutes ces phases et votre cerveau
il commence avec les ondes bêta dont on
a parlé puis vous avez les signes que
vous connaissez bien et qui vous
préviennent que vous êtes fatigués du
coup vous allez vous coucher vous vous
allongez vous fermez les yeux et vous
passez en ondes alpha vous entré alors
dans la phase d'endormissement vos ondes
cérébrales ralentissent encore jusqu'au
rythme thêta comme on l'a vu et tout
votre organisme se prépare à se mettre
en mode veille
enfin non en mode sommeil mais bon vous
avez votre coeur votre respiration
ralentissent le mouvement de vos
intestins et de tous vos autres organes
aussi vos muscles se détendent évoque
températures baissent ensuite vous entré
dans une phase de sommeil léger c'est à
dire que ça y est vous dormez mais c'est
pas fini parce qu'au bout de 20 minutes
vous entrez dans ce qu'on appelle le
sommeil profond avec des ondes
cérébrales très lente les fameuses ondes
delta à ce stade ça devient plus
difficile de vous réveiller et c'est le
moment où vous récupérez le mieux les
fameuses sommeil réparateur si vous vous
ça ça dure environ une heure et arrivent
ensuite le fameux sommeil paradoxal on
l'appelle comme ça parce que vous dormez
votre corps est complètement amorphe
mais vos ondes cérébrales elle et
carbure à fond elle ressemble pas mal à
celle que vous avez quand vous êtes
réveillé et vos yeux gigote dans tous
les sens on appelle ça des airs e m
ça veut dire rapid eye movement
mouvement au dessus et à rapide
c'est pendant cette phase de sommeil
paradoxal que vous rêvez que vous vous
en souveniez après ou pas et voilà après
un quart d'heure de sommeil paradoxal
vous avez bouclé un cycle de sommeil
d'environ 1h30 90 à 100 minutes ça varie
un peu et ça recommence comme ça entre
quatre et six fois par nuit
mais il faut savoir que pendant la
première moitié on a du bon gros sommeil
profond bien réparateur alors que
pendant la seconde on a plus de sommeil
léger est paradoxale voilà ça c'est ce
qui se passe quand tout va bien
le problème c'est que tout ne va pas
toujours bien on estime qu'en france un
tiers de la population à des troubles du
sommeil quand même parler de ceux qui
dorment pas trop mal en général mais qui
peuvent la sceller sale période
alors les troubles du sommeil c'est quoi
globalement si on veut schématiser c'est
trop ou pas assez
trop c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hypersomnie c'est à dire faire des
nuits plus longues que la moyenne et ou
avoir une somnolence la journée avec
besoin de faire des bonnes grosses
pièces pour tenir le parfois même avec
des siestes qui prennent un peu en
traître comme dans le cas de la
narcolepsie c'est à dire le fait de
s'endormir comme ça n'importe où
n'importe quand sans prévenir
l'hypersomnie parfois on en fait on sait
pas trop pourquoi on appelle ça une
hypersomnie idiopathique
ça c'est un terme un petit peu stylet
pour dire qu'on sait pas parfois il ya
une cause qui dérègle le rythme
circadien comme un médicament une
maladie le jet lag etc
et puis il ya le pas à ses seins que
vous connaissez pas ce que c'est celui
qui concerne le plus de personnes les 1
seconde ça peut être des difficultés à
s'endormir ou des difficultés à rester
endormi genre on se réveille plusieurs
fois et on a du mal à retrouver le
sommeil où on se réveille trop tôt le
matin et puis il ya les insomnies de
perception c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on dort très mal ou
quand on dort peu voire pas du tout
alors qu'en réalité on a un sommeil tout
à fait satisfaisant là encore les
origines peuvent être très diverses
alors idiopathique
non non vous savez ce que ça veut dire
ou liés à des causes identifiable mais
globalement les causes les plus
fréquentes c'est une maladie physique ou
un trouble si des médicaments ou des
substances qui perturbent le sommeil le
stress et de manière plus générale une
hygiène de vie qui ne colle pas avec des
bonnes habitudes de sommeil alors c'est
pas possible de faire du cas par cas
on appelle temps 1 1 mais je vais quand
même vous proposer quelques petits trucs
qui peuvent vous aider à régler vos
problèmes de sommeil et notamment les
insomnies première chose à faire essayer
de trouver une cause
parlez-en à votre médecin qui va
chercher une maladie ou un trouble qui
perturbent le sommeil
pour vous donner un seul exemple l'apnée
du sommeil vous respirez peut-être très
mal pendant votre sommeil
mais vous en avez absolument pas
conscience mais résultat là vous dormez
mal et vous êtes fatigué toute la
journée
pour ça il ya des traitements et ça peut
vraiment vous changer la vie
la cause peut être psychologique
n'hésitez pas à aller voir un ou une
psychologue il y en a même qui sont
spécialisés dans les troubles du sommeil
ensuite il ya deux trois trucs que vous
pouvez faire la journée et qui peuvent
vous aider
le soir venu l'activité physique d'abord
du sport idéalement le matin ou même
juste marcher régulièrement ou prendre
les escaliers quand vous en avez
l'occasion voir la lumière du jour ça
réguler le rythme circadien donc si vous
travaillez à l'intérieur dès que vous
pouvez aller faire un petit tour dehors
et marché y est comme ça vous faites
d'une pierre deux coups il ya aussi la
luminothérapie ou les simulateurs d'aube
pas vraiment fait la preuve scientifique
de leur efficacité mais je vous laisse
voir avant de vous coucher il ya aussi
des trucs à faire et à ne pas faire déjà
éviter les excitants dans l'après midi
ça veut pas dire refuser de voir votre
croche après le déjeuner ça veut dire ne
pas boire de café ou de thé par exemple
ne mangez pas trop lourd le soir dans
l'absolu le repas de la journée c'est le
petit déj le déjeuner un peu moins et le
soir on la joue vraiment léger en soirée
ayez plutôt des activités calmes genre
lire un bouquin c'est mieux que
s'exposer aux écrans parce que la
lumière s'annonça surexcités un petit
peu votre cerveau si vous aimez le yoga
ou la relaxation vous faites vous
plaisir ça peut être une bonne idée ça
vous permettra d'évacuer le stress et
éventuellement les idées qui peuvent
tourner en boucle dans votre tête avant
d'aller se coucher à et sachez que
pendant l'orgasme le corps libère des
endorphines qui sont des substances très
sympa qui ont plein de propriété hyper
plaisante parmi lesquels favoriser
l'endormissement
oui ça donne couchez-vous à des horaires
réguliers autant que possible a dit
rentrez au monastère n'est faut quand
même savoir que ça aide
et souvenez vous que quand vous êtes
fatigué si vous attendez plus d'un quart
d'heure avant d'aller vous coucher
le train du sommeil ils passent et ils
pénètrent plus d'une à deux heures avant
de revenir mais n'y a pas que ce que
vous faites avant de dormir qui compte
il ya aussi où vous dormez fait ce qu'il
faut pour être dans l'obscurité
tirez les rideaux fermer les volets
éloigner les objets qu'on des led ou qui
produisent de la lumière portable mettez
votre téléphone à charger dans une autre
pièce en mode avion et si vous pouvez
pas parce qu il vous sert de réveil va
acheter un réveil et si vous avez peur
de rater un appel important au pire sur
certains modèles
vous pouvez ne faire sonner votre
téléphone que pour certains
correspondants en cas d'appels répétés
merci de votre attention
changez de matelas de temps en temps une
literie défoncé ça aide pas à dormir
fait le silence autour de vous alors
d'accord c'est pas facile on gère pas
toujours ses voisins mais si vraiment
c'est pas possible
petits bouchons d'oreille alors je
travaille et que l'on dort mieux
onfray régler la température de votre
chambre plus basque dans le reste de
votre appartement alors au rayon des
mauvaises idées maintenant l'alcool
alors c'est vrai ça peut aider à
s'endormir mais ça perturbe les cycles
du sommeil du coup il devient de moins
bonne qualité et en plus on a tendance à
moins dormir quand on n'a nulle et si
vous n'arrivez pas à trouver le sommeil
ou à le retrouver
après vous êtes réveillé restez pas dans
votre lit à tourner dans tous les sens a
les yeux rivés sur votre réveil être
énervé à cause d'une insomnie ou avoir
peur d'en faire une c'est une cause
d'insomnie donc c'est le serpent qui se
mord la queue
mais si vraiment ça veux pas insister
pas rallumer vous qui n'est un peu on
fait des exercices de relaxation ou de
cohérence cardiaque par exemple il ya
des applis très bien pour ça alors bien
sûr il ya aussi des traitements sûrement
entendu parler des compléments à base de
mélatonine
par exemple quand ils contiennent plus
de 2 mg de mélatonine
ils sont considérés comme des
médicaments donc il faut avoir une
ordonnance de son médecin mais du coup
il y en a qui sont en vente libre parce
qu'ils contiennent 1,9 mg de mélatonine
il faut savoir que leur efficacité fait
pas vraiment l'unanimité et que
certaines études ont alerté sur les
risques d'effets secondaires
neurologiques ou psychique et au niveau
du système digestif ou de la peau par
exemple ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
prendre ça à la légère il faut pas faire
n'importe quoi
le mieux c'est quand même d'en parler à
son médecin bon et si vraiment rien ne
marche
il ya des centres spécialisés dans les
troubles du sommeil
là encore parlez-en à votre médecin voit
la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout font rien
porter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]